This week planting trees to save the planet from wildfires toillegal logging. The world's forests have been decimated in the
21st century. Why reforestation is so important. If it's donecorrectly monoculture plantations don't have any biodiverse long
very low biodiversityand they don't capture as much credit. And as natural forest
carbon offsets are a win win. On paper companies get to net zeroand countries protect their forests. But our investigation finds
that not all projects are what they seem. As we begin to look atthe carbon offset projects themselves what we've found is that
the environmental benefits claimed by these companies are notactually what they seem to be. Plus crimes against the planet
newly defined eco side could soon be a crime tried by theInternational Criminal Court putting guilty CEOs on the same
level as war criminals. Damage to nature is simply not takenseriously enough. And we're seeing on an ever more apocalyptic
scale what the results of that is. I'm Kailey Lienz in New Yorkand this is Bloomberg Green.
We've lost 10 percent of the world's forests in the last 20years and the pace of destruction is not slowing down. According
to Brazil's the space research agency last month was the worston record for Amazon rainforest destruction with 180 square
kilometers lost. And after major forest fires in the AmazonCalifornia and Australia. Global attention has now turned to
reforestation but it's not as simple as just planting trees.Bloomberg's Oakeshott Ratty explains three lessons about trees
and climate.Freeze on the simple climate solution. You think they are.
Entries already have a vacuum cleaner for the sky. Thesemajestic species of all shapes and sizes soak up carbon dioxide
and store it away for decades or even centuries. But we arelosing trees at an alarming rate.
If you've lost 10 percent of the world's forests in the last 20years that works out to losing a football field of road to
freeze every second. If you want fees to be a climate solutionto their full potential we don't just need to stop deforestation
but reverse the trend by growing forest cover. Sounds simpleright. But years of trial and error have shown that it is not
experts who have studied tree planting program. Say there arethree key lessons. One grew a forest not a plantation. Don't
just plant one or two fast growing species of trees. They maysoak up carbon in the short term but the lack of diversity makes
them vulnerable to pests droughts floods and forest fires. To becareful in choosing where you plan the trees trees may soak up
carbon but they also play a significant role in absorbing oraffecting sunlight. Forest closer to the poles may actually
increase the warming of the planet. Scientists have found thatgrowing trees closer to the equator is much more beneficial.
Tree beware the risk of green colonialism. If the world needs toplant a trillion more trees then we will need land the size of
China to grow them. That kind of expansion will pit human needsagainst global climate goals. She planting should not conflict
with the needs of local people. Instead working with localpopulations helps ensure that the trees are means sucking up
carbon for much longer. Done right. Trees will be a key climatesolution but trees on a get out of jail card. They won't be
effective unless the world cuts emissions first. This is netzero. I am sure ready for more stories like this. You can find
us on your favorite platforms. Joining us now to talk more aboutthis is Merrill Vander Marc. She is from the Rainforest Action
Network an organization that was founded in 1985 with an aim toend deforestation and uphold indigenous human rights. Merrill
it's great to speak with you. Let's talk about the problemfirst. When we talk about forest destruction what scale are we
talking.And huge mutko just last year we lost over four million hectares
of tropical forests around the world. And this tends to beincreasing. So yeah there's huge deforestation issues. We're
losing our our main forests which holds huge biodiversity thatit hold most of the biodiversity we have on Earth from the rest
of Earth and that are key to to fight climate change. Youmentioned the biodiversity impact. What else what else do we
need to worry about when we think about losing our forest. Whatother issues result from it.
So first are really important carbon sink as our feet lenses areoften together found in the same places as first. So that's a
huge important issue that should have those carbon sinks and infact we should expend them so that we can capture more carbon
and mitigate the effects of climate change. As I said they arethe major. They hold most of the biodiversity terrestrial
biodiversity on earth. So that's very important for keepingbiodiversity and increasing our resilience for the impacts of
climate change.First also home to millions of people that the right to defense
for their livelihoods on the farm. So protecting these forest isalso a way to protect indigenous people traditional communities
that really use the forest as their subsistence. Obviouslycarbon offsets are getting a lot of attention as the world looks
more toward net zero. Is there anything about the carbon offsetmarket that worries you. Do you get concerns that money may be
going to the wrong places.Yes absolutely. First because carbon offsets they're not the
same as decarbonisation. Right. An offset is just the way to itcan be just a way to continue polluting while someone else does
the work of protecting a forest or reducing emissions. And weneed to reduce the emissions of the world's to such a degree
that we're going to need all the companies and banks to reducetheir own emissions before to start thinking about ISE about
offsets. And then there's a huge issue with respectingindigenous people's rights and vocal communities rights because
some of these offsets are being imposed. Stop them on localcommunities in their act. They're having huge impacts on their
livelihoods some of their rights defenders and they're not doingwhat they should but there is made to do which is to protect the
climate and forests. Thank you so much to Van Vander Mark fromthe Rainforest Action Network. Coming up these trees are not
what they seem. A Bloomberg investigation uncovers the murkyworld behind carbon offsets and why the route to net zero might
be harder than just planting forests. This is river green.
This is Bloomberg Green. I'm Jennifer's office a sergeant in NewYork with your Green Brief VIX relations have adopted this
wholeheartedly.Asia's richest man says businesses need to go green to survive.
Mukesh Ambani told the Qatar Economic Forum that he plans totransform all of the units in his conglomerate Reliance
Industries as he aims for net zero by 2035. His firm got 60percent of its revenue from energy in the last year.
Australia is rejecting a warning about the Great Barrier Reef.The government is opposing an effort by UNESCO to categorize the
world's biggest coral ecosystem as endangered.Australia says the world's reefs are threatened by climate
change but rejects singling out one. And could aluminum be botha cause of climate change and its cure. That's what Goldman
Sachs believes. It says demand is expected to surge with themetal being a key ingredient in green tech like IV's and solar
power. But it's also very carbon intensive. With the bankestimating it generates 2 percent of all global emissions. And
that's your green brief Kaley. Thanks Jen. Net zero is now theholy grail of hundreds of companies and governments around the
world and planting trees may hold the key to progress. Consumerscan now fly by and eat safe in the knowledge that the businesses
their money goes to are slashing emissions in the name ofclimate. Or are they. For many reducing emissions is certainly a
part of the solution. But carbon offsets may be an equal or evenbigger part. Billions now flow into projects trying to balance
the carbon books. But the big question is do they work.It's very important given the nature of the climate crisis right
now for the general public to have an understanding of whatprogress is or is not actually happening. And I think many
readers right now they'll see these hundreds and hundreds ofcompanies making these big bold climate claims.
And they would be forgiven to think that you know we're well onour way to meeting the emission reduction trajectory we need to
be on. And the reality of the matter is we're just not on thattrajectory. And a and a key reason for this sort of disconnect
is the use of offsets that aren't doing what they claim to bedoing. My name is Ben Elgin. I wrote the story about how the
billion dollar market for carbon offsets is setting back thefight against climate change.
My name is Mark Trexler. I've worked in climate change for thelast 30 years. I was actually hired by the World Resources
Institute in Washington to work on the first carbon offsetproject in 1988. In terms of defining a carbon offset that one
of the beauties so to speak of greenhouse gases sort of thesilver lining of greenhouse gases. When you put up a molecule of
CO2 into the atmosphere it can be anywhere in the planet inseven days. And therefore if there is an option to reduce
emissions on the other side of the planet and you can do thatvery cheaply as compared to doing it in your factory for example
then why not pay that person that factory on the other side ofthe planet to reduce their emissions. Then you are in a sense
offsetting your emissions and the atmosphere doesn't really seeyour emissions anymore.
We've seen a huge surge in companies making big proclamationsabout how they're going carbon neutral or zero and out all of
their carbon emissions.We began looking at these corporate claims of dramatically
reduced emissions and we noticed so many of these companies wereusing carbon offsets to to to achieve these aims. And as we
begin to look at the carbon offset projects themselves what wefound is that the environmental benefits claimed by these
companies are not actually what they what they seem to be. Andas we sort of saw and spotted a number of these very aggressive
carbon offset projects which appeared to be generating inflatedcredits or bogus credits we saw a number of them were associated
with the Nature Conservancy.This surprised us the Nature Conservancy is the world's biggest
environmental group. They have about a billion dollars a year inrevenues and they've been around for seven decades.
They've preserved about one hundred and twenty five millionacres of land.
And they've done so many good works over the years and they'vebeen very strong in terms of working with corporate partners.
Then CAC.
If you look at for instance Disney that's a sprawling companywith theme parks and cruise lines that burn up diesel fuel they
have office buildings and television studios that consumeelectricity.
So these companies are trying to make major major reductions intheir carbon footprints. But it's very difficult to change these
fundamental ways their businesses operate to. Disney has been abig buyer of carbon offsets that are orchestrated by the Nature
Conservancy. One of the projects that they buy from is calledPennsylvania Ridges and that's a plot of land. Most of the land
is actually about a three hour drive outside of Philadelphia.Interestingly this land three thousand of these acres was
actually acquired by the Nature Conservancy in the late 1990s.This land was imminently threatened. There was a pending logging
contract on this land. So they they do what they have done sowell for all of these years which is they go out they raise
money from local philanthropists and they go buy this land toprotect it from developers and loggers.
And at the time according to an archive version of the NatureConservancy Web site that when they were proudly announcing this
deal they said these threats have been abated because of thisacquisition by the Nature Conservancy. So it's really
interesting now. Fast forward two decades to earlier this yearwhen they put forward this carbon project. And if you look
through it this land is a key part of that carbon project. Andwhat they're now saying is this land is now once again
imminently threatened. Seventy two percent of the trees aregoing to be cut within five years. Now this is just astounding
because this land is owned by the Nature Conservancy. They donot clearcut land that they've bought through for philanthropic
donations.So this scenario that they've put forward to get carbon revenues
is not really plausible. And what that means is when you haveDisney coming in and buying these credits
when it eventually lowers its carbon footprint because of thesecredits. Well that won't be a credible or truthful claim by
Disney.So the Nature Conservancy defends vigorously these deals. And
and they and others will say look our projects are justfollowing the rules that these registries set up.
So somewhat also put some of the blame on the registriesthemselves because they're setting up the rules which allow
these vapid projects to get up and sold. Most of these NatureConservancy deals are set up and sold on. This exchange is
called the American Carbon Registry. One of the challenges withwith designing carbon offset systems is that there are normally
two people at the table. You have buyers and you have sellers.And to some extent you have policymakers. But. But you know the
buyers and the sellers are really the ones with the expertisewith the with the incentive to really participate hard make a
lot of things happen.And so the challenge there is is that both of them sort of want
the same thing or they're both happy with the same thing.They're happy with low cost offsets and a lot of them.
Ultimately what needs to be what needs to happen is systemicchange. You know we're sort of nibbling around the edges with
some of these different things. We need to change how we produceenergy. We need to change how we transport ourselves. We need to
change what and how we eat. You know we we need systemic changeassociated with transitioning to a low carbon economy.
A lot of what we're doing today is not promoting systemicchange. It's sort of trying to stick your your thumb in the dike
to preserve the current system. And and at the end of the daythat can't really work.
Coming up environmental destruction harms us all but could thepeople behind it soon be tried alongside war criminals. A panel
lawyer thinks they should and is drafting a new definition ofeco side to do so. This is Bloomberg Green.
From Bloomberg's headquarters in New York I'm Kate Lines andthis is Bloomberg. GREENE Well global environmental rules are
patchy at best which means holding multinational actors toaccount can be tricky. Even when companies are taken to court
fines are often absorbed and business continues. But now a panelof lawyers is drafting a definition of eco side to submit to the
International Criminal Court in hopes that raising environmentaldestruction to the level of genocide will rein in some of
humanity's worst excesses.This decade is gonna be decisive in how we approach dealing with
the climate crisis. Dealing with ecological crises and dealingwith each side is a bit like going to the record say climate
change if you like. It is a symptom and you know mass damage anddestruction of ecosystems is actually one of the root causes.
When BP spill 210 million gallons of oil into the Mexican Gulfin 2010 it wasn't just seabirds and dolphins that were the
victims. Ten years on the Natural Resources Defense Councilestimates that the overall cost of fisheries in the Gulf was
eight point seven billion dollars with a loss of more than 20000jobs. White House energy adviser Carol Browner called it the
worst environmental disaster the U.S. have faced. BP was hitwith a record fine of 20 billion dollars but deepwater drilling
continues to this day. A growing number of people think that thecourts did not go far enough. Damage to nature is simply not
taken seriously enough. As we can see our economic system is setup around maximizing profit and doing so within certain ground
rules like you know you don't kill anybody. But those groundrules don't include serious damage to nature. And we're seeing
on an ever more apocalyptic scale what the results of that is.So what if there was a different way. What if instead of
shrugging off fines as exceptional expenses decision makerscould be tried alongside war criminals and those who committed
genocide.It may sound extreme but that's what supporters of eco cite law
want. The international criminal law is really about humansurvival and human dignity. Its famous focus on the human race
and genocide. Elimination of a human grief or crimes againsthumanity. What could be more of an international crime. In other
words a crime that no matter where it occurs on the planetaffects all of us. The destruction of our environment. Kate's
McIntosh and Jo Jo Mazza are part of a panel of lawyerscurrently drafting legislation to be presented to the
International Criminal Court. The best chance gets for eco sightto be made into law. It's a long road to ratification but
supporters include French President Emmanuel Macron GratitudeBerg and even Pope Francis. So what we're wanting corporations
to see this as is a God read but also is a challenge. It's likeyou know what we want. We want those CEOs to be saying you know
I can see this coming down the line. It is very sensible. It'sultimately it's almost like a health and safety regulation for
the planet. You know how do we comply with that new health andsafety regulation. We want to be ahead of that curve because we
want to be placed in a way to take things forward in a way thatis sustainable and that is actually helping the planet to thrive
rather than destroy. As we getthe lawyers pursuing eco side believe it must be on a level with
genocide or crimes against humanity. It might be hard to imagineCEOs in the dock alongside dictators and despots but it's hoped
the threats of prosecution will be enough to change behavior.We're not talking about genocidal maniacs or warlords trying to
win territory. We're talking about basically reasonable peoplewho are going about their business. And I can't imagine that
those people would feel comfortable about being potentiallyprosecuted as an international criminal in the same way that
they might feel quite comfortable about dealing with fines thatwould result from civil suits fought against them.
Despite optimism and widespread public support eco side laws areat least a few years off. Even if the ICC accepts the new
definition of eco side one of its 123 member states will stillneed to propose it and the rest will have their turns squabbling
over the details. Only then could enforcement begin. Lawyersestimate that could take up to four years. But that might be
just what businesses need to get their houses in order. Ofcourse they will need to be a transition period. I'm not going
to you know make any bones about that. You know if we broughtthis low in tomorrow it would be chaos. It's not about an
instant change that's going to somehow you know dump everybodysomewhere that they're completely unfamiliar and don't know what
to do. This is about looking at something that's coming down theline because something like this will have to come sooner or
later.We're looking at something coming down the line within the next
few years that inspires compliance pathways transition policies.You know all of these kind of things that will need adjustments
that will need to be made but will need to be made with a verydifferent future in mind a future that we all know we have to
approach. The power of eco side law lies in criminalizing thedestruction of nature on an individual level.
Next time a company causes an oil spill its decision makerscould be facing jail time and that personal accountability is
what its supporters say will drive the change. Effectively whatyou're looking at is an individual being held to account because
they're in a decision making position within that project. Andthat's precisely again where the power comes in because it's
easy to hide behind the corporate veil and have your companyfined for something you made the decision for. But once that
such protection is removed you're going to think a lot harder.It's a serious concentration for the mind. That's it for this
week's edition.But keep the conversation going.
Follow us on Twitter at Climate. I'm Kailey Leinz in New York.And this is Bloomberg Green.